for natasha's parents it has been an
unbearable wait
four years after their daughter took her
own life a judge has ruled that the
university of bristol discriminated
against her disability by failing to
adjust assessments
given her social anxiety there are no
winners today natasha is still dead
the university's credibility's in
tatters
how is that a victory
it's only what we do from now going
forward but is actually meaningful
if these changes
aren't implemented
it's highly likely more people will
suffer an unnecessary death natasha was
in her second year of studying physics
in bristol when she was diagnosed with
chronic social anxiety the court heard
she suffered with debilitating shyness
much of this case centered on an oral
presentation that natasha was due to
give in a large lecture theatre
alternative ways for her to participate
were presented but they were never
implemented
her body was found in her flat
on that same day she was due to be
assessed
the judge said that the university
discriminated because it knew or should
have known that miss abraham's mental
health was preventing her from
performing
the university extended its sympathies
and said in a statement we believe staff
in the school of physics worked
incredibly hard and diligently to
support natasha during her time with us
and it was due to their efforts that she
was receiving specialist mental health
support from the nhs our staff's efforts
also included offering alternative
options for natasha's assessments to
alleviate the anxiety she faced
the university has been ordered to pay
more than fifty thousand pounds in
damages it has said it is considering an
appeal
the solicitor representing natasha's
parents says this should be a wake-up
call across the board
all institutions universities workplaces
need to be aware of their obligations
under the equality act there is a mental
health crisis amongst young people in
this country universities are in a
particular position to be able to help
those young people
this is a landmark case one which all
universities are likely to review to
check they're doing enough to help those
with mental illness
natasha's parents say they will continue
to campaign
so that others don't suffer like she did
damn white is sky news in bristol